um how about this this is interesting
fighting news but it's it's it's
this news just broke and uh it's good
that we got sergio shacon uh
the x xbox yo jake paul is gonna fight
conor mcgregor
is that that's that can't be signed
sealed and ready to go yet
pimpy says yes
he's in talks with it i don't know if
that's you know what he's in talks
that probably will go down one thing
that people have to realize now if
you're like a boxing
purist or martial art purist listen
this is the future of fighting right now
it's gonna definitely uh have its own
lane
and continue to go on this way there's
too much money involved
and there's too many people tuning in so
i wouldn't be surprised if that fight
goes on
and you know what it would be
entertaining as hell these guys are both
showmen
uh and it'll be fun to watch just as we
witnessed this past weekend
i personally didn't like to see nate
robinson get stretched out like that
i felt bad for him yeah he signed the
paper he knew what he was in for
or maybe he didn't know what he was
there for do you think do you think
with all your boxing experience you
could win in a fight against nate
robinson
nate robinson i could probably whoop
jake paul will probably work my ass
yo he's young man and he's like he's
felt
he fell in love with the sport yeah and
he's only 23 years old yeah like he can
actually be a for real boxer
yeah yeah i mean you know listen i could
i could probably i could probably uh
do my thing for you know a few rounds
but his conditioning man he's 21 years
old he might he might
now let me let me ask you this let me
ask you this obviously you know boxing
inside and out
if jake paul was to fight an actual
professional boxer would he get
like his head like ripped off like
i think i i think he uh
would lose against
most pro boxers uh but any athlete
such as nate robinson or any other
youtuber
i think he got on smash something about
his balance
and his uh his athleticism it's very
surprising to me he's a big guy who
started boxing just two years ago
it's pretty impressive the way he moves
so you think you think he could actually
beat some professional boxers right now
you know it depends what level you know
anyone could be a professional boxer
people don't know that like why don't
you put your money up then son do it for
your family
you're breaking up i can't hear you yo i
said put your money up why don't you do
it for your family i didn't actually
hear you i'm just trying
yo you're the only dude i've ever met in
my life that the santa hat is tied on
his head
no matt pointy kkk in the house like
that
yo somebody in the chat said sergic
likes the most dirtbag elf
i got cocaine right here laced in the
rim yeah
hey everybody it's the bay ridge boys
first of all wanna welcome you to our
patreon page
take a look around we're very happy to
have you you're gonna
enjoy it we have a five dollar level a
ten dollar level twenty five dollars a
hundred dollars i mean we go
wild here at this patreon so this is
really really really where the wild
laughs happen this is the kind of stuff
you can't hear unless it was pre-2016
yeah that's what it is so
enjoy early access for episodes that you
can listen to
first five dollars gets you all the
audio content we do
ten dollars gets you all the video
content we do and tons of
other bonus content for our higher tiers
enjoy
you yeah